Man like Shaquille O'Neal, he thinks he's bad
He doesn't want to link me
I'm ready to link him now you understand what i'm saying
I've dealt with man like him, its like David & Goliath
You know what i'm saying? That Shaq is expired
You understand?
Your careers over, big man. You understand? There's a new man in town
Man come from the U.K mans squaddeded it up
Squaded up
You dun know
Yeh yeh
Yo!
You dun know, it's big shaq, boom
I'm not even going to waste my time and rap, man's just going to talk over this
Yo!
Alright, you don know, boom, let's go
Yeh, alright, yo!
Shaquille O'Neal
You think you're bad?
Cause your knees are made of steel
But you're not, you're moist
Man's see your armpit drippin'
In the changing room
Yeah, alright, cool
Uh!
They call you big Shaq
But you're not big Shaq
And your teeth bare plaque
Mine no plaque
You're just wack
Cut some slack
Look at your back
It's just black
I'm fin
I don't sing
Man heard you sing
Ring a ding ding
Phone goes ping
I ling ling
Yo!
Shabado
Look at your toenails
They're black
Mouth is white, like crack
You don't want to see me
In the lab
Man hit your head
Like slab
You dun know
Huh!
Man don't even waste my time
I don't send, you understand what I'm saying, man just got me in the booth
Fresh off the dome, yo!
The ting go skrr pa pa pa katakaka tun tun tuka tun tun
When I see man
Ku tu kun tun tun tun
Casualty
Kutukum tum tum
yeh, yeh
yeh yeh, aye Shaquille O'Neal
I'm in New York City
If you're bad come link me, mans in a hotel
But you're not going to come
You get me? Mans called big shaq
But you can't even roll by yourself, you need your body guards
I'm in-im in-im in America big man!
Come, COME LINK ME BRUV!
Say notin, I'm here
Hold tight drizzy, hold tight Busta Rhymes
Hold tight Puff Daddy
Hold tight DJ Khaled, my brudda, hold tight Cardi B
You don know the ting, bang bang
I'm gone